[Musik]
vatersein ein riesenglück voller
liebevoller anstrengungen für dieses
wesen sorge ich ein leben lang
doch sorgt es auch für mich im kreislauf
von geburt und tod kommt der tag an dem
ich als sein werde
und dann
[Musik]
ab mitte 40 unterstützt mehr als die
hälfte der menschen in der schweiz
angehörige am häufigsten die eltern die
mehrheit davon sind frauen
ich beginne die suche nach kindern die
sich mit dieser sehr persönlichen frage
der verantwortung beschäftigen und
erlebe wie sie sich mit sorge und
fürsorge um ihre eltern kümmern
[Musik]
gary hooper fährt regelmäßig von ihrem
wohnort im kanton solothurn nach zürich
vor kurzem hatte hier 95 jähriger vater
eine schwere hüftarthrose
dass ich immer schlimmer wurden extreme
schmerzen und taschendiebstahl
ihr vater musste ins spital wurde
notfallmässig operiert
und wer operation hat man gesehen hat
dass der in factory sind im verkauf und
den habe ich fragt also wenn das noch
können und das wäre der beitrag sino
will das ist ein exklusiv ist auch
natürlich mit bakterien das
verschlimmert sich rasant und den bayern
gestorben
und die tische im spital da und wir
geboren jetzt operiert deshalb bessere
mit dem keim und muss man das nun ja
hallo traue mir die mehr strom an der
schlacht gewisse gemacht will ich hatte
ein tolles leben verlängere das leader
verlängert
mir ist immer um glas qualität gange
sind froh dass dritte oper heute machen
mit dem künstlichen hüftgelenk was macht
den fans oder was man auch ein
dokumentarfilm ja unter der kuppel ist
eine foto protagonisten ok und die sich
mit der herstellung von der ton ist es
ist ja also nach dresden operation aber
jetzt weiß ich nicht ich besitze ja
erfindet die operationen machen nicht
neu erfindet müsse die unbedingte sechs
wochen pause machen mit risiken und wo
mir natürlich gedanken daran ist desto
besser abschätzen mit risikos im alltag
entstehen
die devise maxi das geht so schnell wie
möglich für die zitronen nicht richtig
mobile ich möchte euch schritt rot
halten oder aber riesig riesig dass ich
mein traum ist es ist ja und zwar
inhaltlich hoch da wird das nicht machen
aber klar ist dass er es mit einem wort
die sache immer schwächer wird wenn man
dem bett in der not das war das war
nicht gut das ist ein muss in der
zwischenzeit muss nur immer sie wo man
sich mit knapper not unternehmen das er
beschäftigt gut neue situation ganz
spontan gemacht aber ja natürlich vom
motorrad und umgesetzt um das loch vor
es ist verstanden hat sich freud für den
das ist wirklich das beruf machen und
dass er die schrift wohnen hat
eingeschränkte für die heilige nutzer
die diese neue situation und die zweite
x sowie beifahrer ist halt ein kunden
sowieso empfehlen und aufgabe zu
unterstützen und
das alles läuft und in vor allem auch
moralisch holte sich dank
[Musik]
hans huber bleibt die nächste nacht in
der klinik wie es dann weitergeht ist
offen
als ich beginne mich mit dem thema
dieses films zu beschäftigen kommt sehe
er als erstes in den sinn
anni seit 70 jahren wohnt sie an ihrer
murley straße im kreis 6 in zürich über
ein jahrzehnt haben wir im gleichen haus
gewohnt und ich dachte immer wenn ich
mal alt bin möchte ich so sein wie sie
[Musik]
ihr mann guido ist vor zehn jahren
gestorben
mit ihm hat sie vier kinder großgezogen
regula ist die älteste möglich töten
und wenn mal irgendwo bis ich sie ist
mit dir wo dein garten ganze haus grüter
und gute frage
ich kann einfach das gefühl sie muss neu
mit einer wo sie erläutert wo sie unter
der ladies
am anderen ende der mühlenstraße hat die
89 jährige vor kurzem eine alters
wohnung bezogen
so war sie mit der miete monika worker
und sind der diener anfang sein
das ist genau das was er sich
vorgestellt hat dann hat sie dann sofort
zurück ich bin nicht das ohr bin ich
sogar meine ich einfach sachen mit dem
mit der natur
[Musik]
aber da hätte es aussuchen die nötige
bedienen
[Musik]
ich begleite gary hooper vom spital in
die wohnung ihres vaters ja bisher im
spitalhof zweieinhalb zimmer onegin exil
unterstützt
unter spitex wo man aber wahrscheinlich
sind im moment wie zucker hand vor der
silberkurs haltet und ich bin einfach
ein wochentag um in die briten aktiv
unterstütze ich ganz klar die gerne
samstag
ich habe vor einem jahr gestorben und
romy ständer papagena like sie jetzt
nach und darum hat sich dann die
situation ist
handler hanseatisches plugin co ganz
unverhofft und dass ich nach hintergrund
sieber um das jetzt einmal hin
ausgerichtet die und hermann dieser
situation vom vortag lagen
wir haben die dem gespräch mit inhalt
dort tritt mit zwei brüder die zusammen
abgemacht dass daraus macht auch
entschädigt werte für und es ist dunkel
mich ein heikler punkt und das wenig das
wird wenig diskutiert es geht nicht um
abzocke und es gab nicht darum dass man
sich bereichert es geht darum dass man
für spesen bis hat und dass das was
einen beitrag leisten entschädigung über
kunden für den vatertag ist als 30 beese
quasi ja
für hubert ins bett machen dass ich
hoffe dass euro
ja das wäre schön
ich danke parat ich parat und kann
eigentlich nur minimalst apparat keine
hoffnung und es ist ganz spannend sieht
man gestorben ist hat sie auch platz
gemacht für eine neue beziehung mit dem
vater
ich habe mich vorher könne vorstellen
dass ich mit ihm 20 minuten telefoniert
entdeckt und das ist die chance
das war das telefon im spital stelle
sozial stellen
das koordiniert für das plug heim für
die reha und den hof wie das ist nicht
weit weg ist das in kuba kann dass das
lieferstart ja mit erstaunen erfahre ich
betagte menschen die vorübergehend in
ein pflegeheim kommen können nicht
selten wieder nach hause
am ende dieser straße finde ich eine
solche geschichte eine voller wunder
freude und traurigkeit
ich mache das ja jetzt gleich mal
wichtig ja wieso läuft es wichtig zu
verdanken dass kirche bilden
ja ja ja ja ich lerne einen offenen
weltgewandten menschen kennen
willi burkhardt 88 war 26 jahre lang
lehrer und ist zeit seines lebens
künstler
seit vielen jahren lebt er getrennt von
seiner frau
[Musik]
ja ja ja
franziska bock und technischer ebene
brett mclean
und die geben sich als volksverhetzer
probiert oft ziel ist nicht gegangen und
hätten
doch natürlich nutzt druck
[Musik]
der hat seine aufbauten im spital
brachte bestanden
denn das gehirn applikation relativ
königspaar der welt ist immer noch sehr
für medikamente geschafft dass er wieder
langsam immer besser und rätsel
er hätte immer besser wieder
kreuzworträtsel los
das im 8
und den habe ich so langsam
[Musik]
da selbst wieder so zwei komische
schnittstellen und ich danke sie sehen
will und ich dann also schätze sachen
schätze man nur kommen
das schätze aber dass er seine villa hat
für bis zu erreichen
als vorgesetzter selber gemacht jetzt
ist so dass die uci vor zwei wochen
und es ist wirklich wenig mit dem hof
nicht zu ideen haben jetzt bis 2 gemacht
er genießt muss er genau richtig wie es
aber noch nicht
hallo hallo hallo ich habe mir glaub
gegend zieht die klassik stiftung jetzt
gehabt noch liege aber darin war
das ist jetzt ihr auffangen interessiert
für die autos wonik das ist sie
kurz nachdem das tops gestorben ist sie
hat sich dann noch mal und dann ist es
aber sieben jahres gange wie sie dann
wirklich und bleibt sie behoben werden
die wünsche ab brach sie hat weder im
quartier blieben sie hat villa oder
minister ausblieben
sie hätte gern im ersten stock hölle
blieben und am baukunst straße
somit muss hauptsache helfer
unterstützen stau zu geraten ab und zu
mal den boden rufen einfach dass die
gruppenarbeit haben die rohstoffe werden
vor allem in sachen ich nicht gehen
macht ob zu geburtstag nein
außerdem werde druck macht rasch trio
verstehe ja und weil ich sonst zu kommen
wenn alles nur geklaut wert um nicht
mehr als 10 kommen anzüge
da wird man noch wie ich aber dass oben
genommen aber sie habe furchtbar gerne
wäre hans fasst es auch im frühling
mieten haben
da geht es eigentlich alles ist aus ihr
eigenständiges sie macht selber sie tue
dir das leben selber organisieren und so
wenn ich die ganze action haben der hand
geschnitten zu werden wenn ich einmal
dürfen sofa und weil sony dann bin ich
müde aber das ist ja cool aus alt mach
doch das bild wenig doch das alles
[Gelächter]
angehört und das mit rückseiten dass
eines tages auch nicht gesagt ich sag
nie
und dann ist ja dann der vorfalls sie
was ihnen ziemlich kalt und dann ist so
genutzt
und dann ist das los gegangen und sie
hat jetzt das hörgerät und sich die pop
und c sich überall wieder beteiligen
sich fast überall
ich bin einfach ich möchte dass ihr gut
geht und dass sie immer größer ist auch
ein oder unannehmlichkeiten ist so dass
das erspart blieb dort dass sie das
nicht muss machen und dass sie es laufen
jetzt nachdem das sie so viel geschafft
verteilung gemacht hat für all das sieht
das einfach noch ich an gemüse
vier wochen nachdem die op ihres vaters
verschoben wurde
treffe ich gehe immer wieder der 95
jährige ist zur rehabilitation in einer
privatklinik mobilisiert intensiviert
intensiv physio und gleichzeitig machen
antibiotika-therapie dass dadurch der
keime weg gott dass gott ist ob es am 14
januar und nachher ich 14 tage volley
medikament bekannt keine machen oder
eben kein fax machen und excel bietet
was man machen da bist du die hitze
bosch mit das scheint mir das noch alle
miteinander gut die physio hat sie nötig
die wirklichkeit
hans huber lebt im moment ohne linke
hüftgelenk und der spitze der solange
die motivation hat hat braucht la paz
wählen und und freud und bloom lake mit
und jetzt wo hoch und rechts und links
spaß am risiko
hans huber kennt das gesundheitswesen er
war bis zu seiner pension technische
assistenz am unispital zürich und
alternative wenn es nicht wie
funktioniert mit dem hilft lang denn
wäre kreisläuferin verliert und wird
dann wahrscheinlich ist auch wieso ist
pflegeheim wohnt
es hilft lang brauchten operation und
das ist die cbm
[Musik]
die laufen wieder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das leben
ich kann nicht sagen dass ich den hype
[Musik]
es war unbedingt zweiter werden
ihm ermöglichen dass er sein wunsch in
völlig gott will es so prof
unser zweiter und ist natürlich auch
erst einmal zu sein da ist es für mich
ist geschwunden geschwunden
und hier beträgt in einem buch das mit
dem lüd im altersheim und sie erkunden
müssen jetzt noch versuchen
[Musik]
die operation bei hans huber ist
geglückt er hat jetzt ein künstliches
hüftgelenk
[Musik]
hier stiegen mit dem europäischen
flugzeughersteller extrem schmal dass
ich es ist glücklich
dank dass das ist auch schnell
was ist der biene bisher stattfinden
das ist einfach der wunsch ich muss mir
jetzt so unterstützt hat freut kann auch
hat als elfter hat und zu machen was für
möglich findet hessische schulen
schweren schaden für das große
unterstützung eine hatte von einer
historischen wende haben wir das wort
ausfahrt dass sie nicht gegen das machen
er hat nicht selbstständig und familie
hand wo so zu strikte sendung weise was
die richter sind
wir sind 4 gegen gesamte mini crash des
kopie erstellt ist gabi hat vor allem
tirol
scotty hat im dezember von new york am
ersten dezember familie sie diagnosen
überholt dass sich und sitzt mit vollgas
geben doch ob ich mal hier
der grat her
in eureka moskau wenn die dass der
monitor verwendet kritik
[Musik]
im zentrum bruder klaus in zürich
veranstaltet anni seit 20 jahren yaz
nachmittag
unterstützt wird sie vom seelsorger
franz ortner kein schnaps
ich bin verantwortlich
klasse geht und als allem blogs hat also
einiges von ihm gibt
[Musik]
theres erzählt mir sie sei fünf gewesen
als ihr vater mit dem aushub seines
hauses begann im gartenhäuschen nebenan
wohnt während der sommermonate ihr
bruder benny nach seiner heirat hat es
ihn nach indien verschlagen
wenn benni weg ist lebt willi alleine
hier mit seinen lastern dem rauchen und
trinken und vor allem ruhige dass er
alkohol halt nicht viel denkt und damit
die grundlage und sind dran was da ich
denke das ist schon gut geht und ich
weiß nicht ob wilking dort wenig
trinkflasche durch dieselben
zurückgezogenheit weiß ich nicht
er macht derzeit wenig früher bis die
metro hierbei um die leidige ja ja nach
menü durch beschaffen ja ja ja ja
im brockenhaus auf dem zollikerberg
kochen regula und anni zweimal im jahr
für die helfer in diesen alltäglichen
momente sind sie stark ja das ist
wirklich super und zwar einfach aber sie
macht ja noch so viel also man ist
dankbar wenn die person die ich dass wir
durch so groß ist der stolz ist
eigentlich so aber jetzt ist es möglich
sehr viel erreichen hat die sturm zieht
das warum so ist das nun mal was genau
richtig unterbezahlt wirkungsstätte
bosse des bvh
nein eigentlich immer das team
eigentlich regiert die erklärung sei
nicht der untergang
ich will nicht dass wir nicht weil sie
die zwölf mitglieder einig sie sich
einig ja ich hab seit warum was sie
immer so hell die strumpfhosen alex und
dunkel rück das selbst gar nicht schön
aus der fassung
unterstützt von holz im sommer und ich
kann erkennt und grüße dich hab ich grad
und christian poser abba hallo also
durch die dunkel liege noch nicht so
ganz wo ich empfinde irgendwie steht und
durch das genommen was nicht
sie haben wir gemacht haben
die traveller kokett und heute begreift
was sie die nachtigall passiert puncto
wohne puncto finanz und ihr großes thema
danke dass du mir jetzt möglich einfach
dann auch noch in angriff nehmen so wie
sie seit immer was passiert wenn ich
sterbe dass ich mir dann gleich doch in
der saubermacher darin derselbe ruhige
und ja ich glaube das ist einfach von
ihrem kreis bedürfnis ist schon immer
gratis oberhaupt
foto familie und sie bestimmt informiert
ja ich denke einfach die ich weiß nicht
ob ich wirklich so bestimmend kommt sie
dass es wirklich bis wird bringen oder
wird fruchten
also dass man dann wirklich zu einem
klaren ergebnis findet zieht es ist ja
ich hab mich wichtig sagt beschorner
luft jetzt mit hofstaat mit aller macht
da rein und da wird aktiviert
[Musik]
da will ich das vielleicht spielt wird
das verläuft spielt textverständlich
antreten wie ich es später extra das
spektrum specials
ja ja ja da kommt unterstütze den
medikamenten auch reichlich getankt
kraft ja mit dem cas richter und
prämierte tag das café nachts liege geht
und er nimmt sein publikum diese macht
den sound und das funktioniert sehr gut
galt kartoffel nur der schöne tag doch
glücklich verdanken habe
kurz vor weihnachten stirbt willys
älteste tochter gabi
[Musik]
ja
plötzlich joh
die bsi el sol gelöscht als sie das
ganze leben kam wird die physischen
immer da
[Musik]
ich habe ja ich glaub im frittieren die
jetzt ja ja ja solle zu einfach wenn es
ging vor dem muskel danke mit ja
[Musik]
geschafft hans huber bald 96 kann nach
hause
das macht mir gerade neben die alte
manche dass sich verrückt was wollt ihr
denn da alles noch mal das gleiche team
gemacht
absolut ja also wirklich sinnvoll ist
das absolut richtige sie aus er wäre
einfach vertreter 18 meter hoch
und dann hat sich entschieden das selbe
zahl und das ist ein riesenbetrag
es ist 50 50 tausend franken für die
reha in der klinik und den selbstbehalt
für die op vier monate ist es her seit
hans huber seine wohnung notfallmässig
verlassen musste
bevor sie ins spital sind sind sie ja
sie mir ungefähr um die halbe 12 in
verbindung und habe mir vorgestellt habe
ja jetzt probiere sage mache hätte hilfe
wie viele frauen früh ok und das
härteste nuss großes thema abgrenzung
das muss man schon mal gedanklich und
bin eigentlich schon immer doch auch
gedanklich gehen aber ich komme gut
abgrenzen sowie spitex ist momentan
nicht viel mehr viel mit da wir viel mit
flugzeugen weniger abliefern ist dann
ist auch die gewissheit er ist gut
aber das hat nicht so gut nicht dass ich
das ja nach südafrika zu seinem 74
manchen hilft aber nicht verstaubt
respekt nicht funktioniert dfb bzw
könntet ihr euch vorstellen vater zurück
nein ich werde ihn jetzt zu mir nicht
klar
die stadt brauche tatsächlich und dann
war es für ihn aber auch klar also das
ist für ihn selber ist das logisch
die hatten ja gott des stiftes telefon
und dusch möglich sprich am morgen
vielleicht also türgriff vitrine weicht
das mit den ohren funktionieren also
machen sie nicht nein sagen dass ich bin
einfach gespannt wie es geht und bin ich
ja immer wieder überrascht wie das
gelaufen ist und wenn er das gemacht hat
mit 17 8
tierisch geht in die ferien zusammen mit
ihrem partner bis hin zu statisch york
und ceo nicht gegangen hieß es
viele haben da sie für mich ein stück
und mdr info
ihr bruder benny ist zurück aus indien
er arbeitet über die sommermonate hier
nun sind wieder beide häuschen bewohnt
[Musik]
bei kindern wollen wir dass sie
möglichst bald selbstständig werden bei
eltern dass sie es so lange wie möglich
bleiben
[Musik]
anni ist aktiv wie eh und je
im märz wird sie 90
[Musik]
hans huber treffe ich drei monate nach
seiner heimkehr nochmals reduziert
heute mache ich halt
do it yourself
die menschen die mich für diesen film in
ihr leben hinein ließen beeindrucken
mich ich habe eine große frage gestellt
und viele kleine antworten
ein jahr nach drehbeginn kann mein sohn
laufen
was wird er tun falls ich dereinst nicht
mehr laufen kann erwarten darf ich
nichts nur hoffen dass unsere beziehung
uns trägt und er dann da sein möchte
[Musik]